it's better off to make 90 000 or 70 000
a year and be ecstatic
than make 165 or 219 and be [ __ ]
miserable and until we redefine success
based on
being at peace and smiling when you wake
the [ __ ] up we will continue to be
confused and that's why i'm all in
because
i'm going to be dead forever
let's talk about how you especially
since thinking back to when you founded
vaynermedia how you built a team that
you could make sure was not just a bunch
of people who looked like you thought
like you uh how did you bring that
intention to how you built the interview
uh by being a dictator on the issue
right like to me it was funny you said
that when you were talking i was
listening when you set up the question
you said the
let's talk about the
let's mention the difficult questions or
the difficult things
and in my brain i laughed i'm like it's
actually incredibly easy
i just tell rob
our chief creative officer that
he can't hire
a this or that like it's
no different
than the cfo says you can't spend more
money than you have or you'll go out of
business
i just tell him and i just tell
everybody like you know i i think you
know people get very spooked by quotas
or bad or this and that like intent
is everything
and so for me
i i was very fortunate i i grew up my
entire life where my mom was my hero
i grew up in incredibly diverse
realities
and i didn't you know i didn't come from
corporate so when i started vayner
we had crazy all over i mean the first
39 people that worked in the agency
didn't have a day of agency experience
they came from all over the place and
you know i think it's it's it's really
not hard i i'm always fascinated when
people come up with excuses of like we
can't find this or this and that i'm
like
like it's just not true
and
you know i really really am happy that
it's such a conversation
at such a high level because it's
changing behavior and that's how comms
work and that makes me happy but
to be very transparent it's just
because i want it to be that way
like everything that is wrong at
vaynermedia is 100 my fault
like not 99
it's just the way it's the truth right
like i hire the chief strategy officer
and wanda
like may make a hire but i'm the one who
hired her
and i trust my people thus i don't know
99 of what's actually going on every
second but in the macro it's me and thus
if i want something to be a certain way
that's on me
whether it's the work whether it's the
way we staff the way we pay where we are
in the world and so i take on that
accountability that's the price of entry
to be a ceo
we are here obviously to talk today
about disrupting uh marketing
destruction in this industry uh i feel
like youtuber are great examples in the
sense that gary disrupted uh this
industry from from coming in from
outside
right you've disrupted it from the
inside um especially coming in from a
major holding company agency and
starting new um
first tell me when you had this
opportunity to start mischief
what did you want to fix about the
experience you had at agencies and what
you felt that being able to build it
from the ground up that you would be
able to fix
that had always bugged you about this
place
well there's one
moment i remember when i was trying to
figure out what i wanted to do and you
know where i wanted to work i really
couldn't find the one place i was super
excited about going to and i thought
that was sad
this industry should have a place that
people aspire to work to
and when i was
researching looking around
what agencies were doing what i found no
fixed address which is our sister agency
and then a line on their website which
really changed everything for me now
mine was simply what would you do if you
weren't afraid
and that was so liberating i was like
that is what i want to build an agency
around is this idea what would you do if
you weren't afraid that's that's like
giving people the freedom to do what's
right and not have to worry about you
know people coming down on them if um if
it doesn't turn out or
you know if the consequences are misread
whatever that is it's like let's just do
it and have fun be smart about it and
see how great we can be when no one's in
our way
gary uh
you mentioned often that certain things
just made no sense to you when you came
into this industry because uh
you know you were able to come in from
the outside and say why do you do this
you talked a lot obviously about the
split between media and creative that
happened in the 80s which a lot of
advertising professionals have grown to
regret over the years and that you've
been working to address what else did
you notice coming into your like that
makes no sense i'm going to not do that
and do you feel the vaynermedia has been
able to follow through on being
different
i mean i definitely feel like we're
different
um
as to answer that part in the front part
i mean 2009's a trillion years ago right
when i came in i didn't understand why
pepsi wasn't on twitter
and so everything for me early on was
why
do the fortune 500 companies not
understand the level of actualized
consumption
on these social media platforms why do
they not understand that facebook fan
pages and twitter are a really big deal
and this thing tumblr's coming and
seemingly could be a big deal and
youtube's a really big deal and
why do they why do they accept these
reports
that say this is how many people
consumed it when these reports are
clearly flawed
if you really break them down
and and why do we justify all of it on
internal mmms that are flawed and why do
we
justify based on headlines and awards
this is subjective creativity which is
amazing creative is the variable of
success but the process of getting there
it's similar it was very similar to me
uh in the way that i saw education there
is nothing more important in the world
than education it's how we move the
needle if you really think about it the
way we have packaged and sold education
in today's world isn't grounded in
common sense to the world we live in
that was my observation in the creative
industry there's nothing
more important than the creative because
it's the variable of why someone decides
they like something or not the way we
made it the costs associated with it and
the way we distribute it didn't make
sense for me in 2009
what's scary for me is in 2022
the world that i saw coming is very
clear to everybody it's here in a lot of
ways right and yet a lot of it is still
being done in similar ways so
most of it
um
didn't make sense and um
and that's why we've gone about it
differently
greg what did you have been able to
recruit some really stellar talents and
veteran talents and rising talent
when they when you first reached out to
them when they first found you uh
because you did not just hire all your
old friends right you easily could have
if it starts an agency they got a great
network you could pack it with all these
folks you worked with the family and
everybody you did not do that what did
you hear from that time you're welcome
to mention anyone by name if you want to
shout them out but uh what did you hear
from them about why they were excited
about coming to mischief no i think
from day one we
created this chip as a place where
people can come and do the best works of
their lives
and we'll get out of the way we'll just
create this atmosphere that
that just emanates
you know freedom
and people just picked up on that they
thought that was interesting i think you
know when we first started we didn't
have a staff and it was me and um young
and kevin were two people i had worked
with we just focused on work let's put
some work out in the world that says
this is what mischief is
and we never wavered from that so
you know i think our best new business
best recruiting tool has always been the
work we do for our clients so getting
that out there and then having people
like ollie you know
push our message in such fun interesting
ways that um i think people were just
kind of naturally drawn to it it felt
kind of like a breath of fresh air i
think in the world where everything has
been kind of
over thought and sanitized and you know
i just felt like a lot of agency
communications had
gone through the whole system by the
time you're sitting today so like it
kind of like gave ollie the freedom goat
don't ask for permission you know just
just
pretend like you would
you're you know you would do what you
would do if uh if you're a person on an
agency and that's kind of you know made
a big difference for us it's shaped our
our brand anyway
uh quick note that we will have time for
q a um to at least take a few questions
uh so be thinking about them i'm sure
you've got several uh gary i do want to
talk about uh the way that you have have
built vaynermedia it's you and i uh
spoke on a podcast once about uh when
you were doing just so many super bowl
ads and i felt like that was the year
where a lot of people like oh gary's
doing some fun stuff with social media
they get it's a social agency they do
tweets and then all of a sudden you're
doing uh how many is like four in one
year maybe more super bowl we've done
eight in three years eight super lives
in three years and uh and that was like
the moment that i felt like a lot of
agencies were like oh [ __ ]
they're real uh what what did you feel
like going in terms of disruption of
moving into this space that we're gonna
do
really big really bold work that's gonna
redefine social that's going to also
just get into these very traditional
spaces what did you want to do to make
sure you didn't just keep making more of
the kind of work that's already been out
there
i didn't think of it that way i thought
of it as
when a client pays you you should do the
thing that they are hoping will happen
that's the only way i've ever thought
about it that's the only way i'll ever
think about it thus
make work that is actually consumed
and inspires consideration to do the
thing whether that's raise cap raise
charity whether it's sell peanuts
whatever it is
do that
super bowl is the most underpriced media
in the world
60 to 100 million people will actually
watch that thing that is profound
social
tick tock linkedin on the organic side
facebook right now on the media side
because of some of the changes with ios
145
we will always follow the actual
consumption of the consumer and we will
then try to make creative that is
contextual to the distribution
in that arena
and we will try to make as much of it as
possible
so that we can actually be relevant to
the many different psychographic cohorts
that exist in society
and that's all i ever think about there
is nothing else it's it was never like
we need to become like this or that
uh and it goes in both directions you
know the agencies right now are like
especially with how i've been playing
out in nft land a lot of people come up
to me like gary we're building a
metaverse for our brand i'm like there's
nobody
there not yet meta's on its way oculus
is really further along in some ways but
at the scale of the cost of building in
decentraland or sandbox like
to us it's only about attention
engineering attention and then making
things that people actually want to
consume
not things that
we want to make and that level of
humility
is really needed in this industry
greg i don't know how often you or if
really you've talked about the
experience of your your
transition i'll let you uh decide how
personal you want to get about this but
i do think you have a fascinating
example i i've been in this situation
i'm sure many people in this audience
have been in the situation of losing
your job which is is gutting in a way
that if you've not experienced it um
it's it's very hard to describe um but
then you really just rose from the ashes
in this really amazing way but you were
at a really difficult point in your
career where you could have just walked
away
uh but you decided to do something
different
tell us a little bit about where your
head was at in that moment and what
advice you would give to anyone who ends
up in a situation like that yeah
it's never easy i've said that but you
know
if you think back to march 2020
everyone was in the state of shock
everyone
we were experiencing something that no
one had ever experienced a massive
pandemic with lockdowns and financial
crisis that we had
no precedent before so it wasn't like it
was just me right so when it happened i
kind of like took a step back and go
okay the world has shifted i can feel it
so
the next thing i do i want to be i want
to be in the part of
the world the way it's going versus
trying to retrofit something that has
been you know
rooted in the past and trying to keep up
so i almost saw this a lot of this is
liberating you know there's a moment of
like oh [ __ ] now what am i gonna do and
um
is this it for me and then that didn't
last for less than a day i was just
otherwise i was like okay i have this
blank slate in front of me
and no one has built anything based on
what's happening today because we're
still in it so
what if i could be the one that built
something that would felt like it was
of the moment for tomorrow
and just the way we work and just the
way agencies felt i felt that clients
wanted that too
immediately when we started meeting with
clients it just got the sense that they
felt we were somewhat refreshing because
we didn't approach meetings the same way
we're just you know we're all just even
clients i think we're feeling like we
just need to be human at this moment we
don't need to be corporate robots
and i think that
of
of the times i think everything kind of
came together to form mischief in the
way it did
and um you know we still
continue to do that
just
let's never
we we try to eliminate the phrase that's
how we always did it
you know as soon as as soon as you get
free yourself from that and just go okay
maybe we did it that way but
today's a different day you know so just
keep it going
uh we are about to get to q a uh if you
don't have any questions we're just
gonna spend 15 minutes talking about
baby nut and puppy monkey baby so um
i encourage you to have some uh but
before we get to that gary i i did want
to ask about comfort zones i know you're
not a person who's always been held back
by such things but a lot of people in
this industry do feel like they're
constantly having to press themselves
out of a comfort zone of a business that
you could have stayed in the businesses
you launched at the beginning you could
have sold them and just gone to mayorka
or whatever but you kept launching new
businesses vayner nft
is that do you find yourself in pushing
yourself to always try something that's
going to be a little different a little
harder than the last thing you built and
what would you tell people who maybe
feel like they're not pushing themselves
hard
i don't i don't oh
i don't think about it thanks brother i
don't think about it as um thank you i
don't think about it as uh thank you i
don't think about it as
pushing myself at all i think about it
from the standpoint of i want to be
happy
and so
you know when i was seven and everybody
went outside it was fun for me to make a
lemonade stand that was my dna some
people like to sing some like golf some
like cooking some love music
you know i just really think it's cool
to play business
i genuinely enjoy it and
and so it's not like i want to
like
push myself to win you know like i love
competition and all those things and
business but it's it's genuinely fun i'm
curious i'm like i wonder if we can do
this i'm curious if this would work
but what does drive me in the decisions
of the new companies we start in the
holding company is
this is something that we can do better
at a better price
which is valuable for what the ecosystem
wants um this is something that i think
consumers are going to do at scale
um so i reverse engineer from like what
makes me happy and what makes me happy
is
uh
trying new things you know to me my
creativity comes in operations
and starting new stuff and trying to
operate into success
um so many of my successful friends are
like man
if you ever just focused on one thing
you would [ __ ] and i'm like i don't want
to i don't want to focus on one thing
i'd rather fail or
do less
success
than
than not do my art and my art is trying
to stand up different businesses try
different things i really enjoy it so
you asked me
what makes gary interesting
i think we learned a lot about that
today but um
i would say you know haven't thought
about it it's like gary is 100 in
everything he does
you never see him going through the
motions man
you're just like fully committed even in
every conversation so you know that's
that's not right
you know what it is back to like
everybody like on some real human [ __ ]
with each other like
you're gonna be dead forever
right when you die
it will be dead forever
you have not been alive for a very long
time like before you were born earth was
really [ __ ] happening for a long ass
time
we are here for a [ __ ] nanosecond
unfortunately that will be and you may
be surprised me saying this
because for me i'm gonna do me
regardless unfortunately the world even
in france unfortunately the world works
a lot
we work a lot if you eliminate sleep
out of your life cycle and think about
how much of your entire life will be
work it's a high percentage
stay-at-home mom and dad did it work
right
to not fight
for that to be at least good [ __ ] solid
and and what are you thinking about if
you dislike it
like if you if you are genuinely not
happy waking up doing what you're doing
you literally need to stand up right now
call your boss and quit i'll lend you
some money you'll pay me back
and so to that point i'm all in because
i'm incredibly logical about this
it's a nanosecond
to compromise
just peace of mind
and this is why we need multiple
different conversations you know any
people could start
great companies as well
if they just lived within their means
greg may have the capacity with his
co-founders to build a very very big
agency that may create a certain level
of finance right
but
it blows my mind that people don't
realize they could start something
that may not pay you millions
but it might pay you tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands and if like how
i just don't understand how people don't
understand that it's better off to make
90 000 or 70 000 a year and be ecstatic
than make 165 or 219 and be [ __ ]
miserable and until we redefine success
based on
being at peace and smiling when you wake
the [ __ ] up we will continue to be
confused and that's why i'm all in
because
i'm going to be dead forever
and this is why it's going to do a panel
of dairy bankers
it's just true
i'm going to take a break from
moderating to have a little existential
spiral and
some questions starting with one of my
favorite people on earth
when you get the mic just introduce
yourself and then tell us your question
uh nate nichols
founder creative director of pallet
group
and co-founder of allyship and action
and i love this panel because i'm
motivated and inspired to be on it next
year my man and so
i've been running the shop for 10 years
and i'm clearly not a white dude
and i have non-traditional backgrounds
so garyvee i'm looking at you yes sir
and
i'm just wondering because i have made
millions in my tenure as an agency
operator but there's still this gap
right from going to the six figure
budgets to the half million to the
million dollar budgets
right
and since i've been on this battle for
like 10 years
how do you how do you go and transition
from you know these
quarter million dollar budgets to like
getting to the half a million to eight
super bowls in a year because i got in
this game like you gonna do super bowl
ads
so where do we go from here
i think there's so many variables to
that right one there's the external and
and keep the mic just because we make
you know
first of all on the record
13 years i've been in this business
some of the most fun satisfying
conversations i've had on whatsapp by
the way
i'm always like where the [ __ ] are you
in the world that we have to be on
what's that um but i really enjoy your
thoughtfulness the answer is
uh it comes in the form of sales
and sales comes in the form of marketing
and so i think for you personally if we
were just chopping
solo which is how i'm gonna answer it
i always want you to make more content
personally
that's how i feel you get there i think
you
need to do more back to i'm looking at
you garyvee when i watch when you do put
out stuff and obviously you put out
stuff to get us to think socially and
things that nature but i just want to
see
more what if campaign content from you
on linkedin like yo
you see what prox is doing if uggs did
this this would happen
i think a lot more people who've got
ideas should put them out for free which
oh every time i tell agency owners this
they get mad at me like i get paid for
this [ __ ] i'm like cool keep doing what
you're doing then
i for you i think it's a content play i
think you're incredibly articulate
you've got charisma
i mean you're pretty [ __ ] good
looking which never hurts
and
but what what's most interesting to me
is you've got good ideas
and i've watched how you've navigated
when you do conferences and things that
nature i think you need to put out more
content about marketing and creative
ideas because the serendipity of those
ideas will find people and it will give
you more at-bats
the world is about more at-bats
the world needs to do its part to give
more at-bats we all can sense that combo
but we we
have to go also into here and say i've
got to create more app ads i believe
content specifically on tick tock and
linkedin for you
around your ideas will be a lead gen to
new business
ones that lead to seven minutes
thank you for that thank you buddy uh if
you meet one person at this festival
meet nate nicholas i agree what an
amazing guy thank you all right who else
has questions for gregor gary
grayson will bring
you hi hi i'm mark i work here at whaler
um i could have started two part
questions so you mentioned the metaverse
and like no one's there so
you don't go there what's that balance
of innovation like when you're thinking
with clients who are like i know no
one's there but i want to try and learn
what's that what's the balance between
that for clients
it's different than for uh for each for
ourselves right i was watching crypto
kitties in 2017
and saying okay
holy [ __ ] that's exactly what i thought
ethereum could do when i bought in 15
but i had to wait until 21 to get loud
because there was enough
scale starting to happen and my
intuition was like it's about to really
happen
right tik tok there's unlimited content
from me on musically
i was watching it so i think i always
remind my team our responsibility
is to
make it be meaningful for the client if
you're doing a metaverse
again in vr metaverse activation for a
b2b activation at the world cup
for your vip clients if you're a brand i
can wrap my head around that they're
going to go to qatar they're going to
put out that's a b to b activation if
you're going to say hey we're going to
sell millions of this or everyone's
going to know it's up to us to respect
how much consumption
is actually happening so i think the
balance is internally we have to stay
curious test learn understand but if
we're going to ask a client to spend
lots of money on something we need to
make sure that there's actual
consumption and that is by the way it's
so fascinating when i come to this town
and talk about television commercials
because i've been very firm on where i
sit on this
it's it's
nothing other than actual consumption
for me and the cost associated with the
consumption that's it it's a very binary
game i just want people to actually see
it
that's a very important part that this
industry needs to talk more about i
think agencies have to be ready before
their audiences are because we have to
be there when they come and networks
only work if there's other people
involved and so right now
this is the learning process and i will
say this in
maybe seven years
more people will be on the metaverse
than they're on uh internet
facebook or whatever that they were
doing 10 years ago because i have a 12
year old daughter and she was born and
raised in another version like roblox
and every one of her kids are proficient
at and demand first so i'm learning from
them but they will grow up as a second
nature that's just the other place they
play the place they live and see
concerts and things like that so
i think
the people in this in this conference
are doing due diligence by learning how
to fight because we'll be ready when
it's ready and
i think that that's the time to bring it
home and and the industries struggle in
my one person's point of view of the
last 20 years
is
the context of the distribution of the
creative
right like to me the better verse will
come at some point
and then my intuition is that this
industry will not be great at it because
they're going to try to force feed what
they want in it instead of reversing the
behavior out of it it is stunning to me
the only word i can use is stunning to
me how little
creative work
is being judged or talked about here
that was done on tick tock when it's the
most consumed platform in the world it
is a [ __ ] joke one thing i've admired
about this
is that when you put stuff in a certain
platform it is so
inbred in that platform it felt like it
was done by people who were enjoying
that platform i think early in uh like
tic toc and some of these other emerging
platforms had been back
the days of twitter friends were coming
in and doing what they did everywhere
else and just retrofitting into that
environment and i think what gary has
managed to do and i think that's one
reason why he's got that yoga up there
is because he can organically live in
that environment and it doesn't feel
like advertising it feels like content
you just have to stumble and to me to
really wrap this in for all of us when i
look at nadia who just joined vader or
rob or mike p greg
like what when i look at them this is
what my brain does the first five years
of youtube fortune 5000 companies
put on their youtube channel their
[ __ ] television commercial
it's youtube when i look at them
and i say to myself the talent of
storytelling these people have in their
soul
what they could do if they made an
actual youtube video that people
actually wanted to watch that would
inspire that person to actually buy
something versus they've been conformed
to 30 seconds
it's the the distribution of television
sucked out the creativity here came the
internet
gave us youtube tick tock
facebook ig gave us all these things and
for some reason the subconscious of the
industry doesn't want to take advantage
of it and continues to put on a pedestal
the work
in the form of a 30-second video
distributed on network television in a
world where people only watch streaming
and their phone it is bananas
[Music]